[音楽]
えっうん
ふーん
てってっん
n ame
んうわぁぁぁ
行ったりパって不満でいたいついていいっ体をねじゃあ外れ像です
タイトルを見てというか僕の体を見たら分かると思うんですけども市場に太りました
今回は何か合致が今回はいつもと何かが違う
そう
[音楽]
痩せる気がしないんですよ年末でも大静脈をどうなってるのかな春とかも
からもう分かりますなんか昔言う復帰と買われてたんですけど今もうからもうなんか
文字なってる雑魚とかほら a 70デイプってわけじゃないんですけどねこっ対内的
な対内的な太り方をすって言う皮下脂肪が厚いというかなーっ
ただのデブじゃないんだよなお礼何なんだろうが東京を去ってからすごい太った気がし
ます東京行ってなんかご飯を食べる機会が増えて感触も増えて一日三食ちゃんと食べる
機会がありましてさんとしても弁当はボリューム max の弁当1日3食絶対食べる
機会があったんでそれで樽町太っちゃったのかなと思います
どれ爺ちゃんちょっと食べないもう良くも悪くも不規則な生活をしてたんで食べるもの
が少なかったからねとか細かったんですけども123ショックドリュー max
ハドリー満点栄養漫研そんな食事を夏休みなんかずっと続けてたら太りました
まあいいことになるかもしれませんがこの女かで健康って言えば来たーー
何うわぁ
わあああああ
あああああこれで健康っているのかよ俺じゃなくなっちゃうやつやー
はじめ8るお前はフリマまずなんて言われてきた
うんまで燃やし燃やすと言われ嫌だったけどもちょっと気に入ってきたりしていてここ
本当にお前 os じゃなくなるぞなんかもうね太り方って方はアレですよ星のせいも
あると思います
災害も水状態なんで他の代謝が悪くなったんで結構に順次35位しか食べてるの間違い
なく太りますからねこの年になるとそれだろ太っちゃったのもあるしや犯したから
サッカーかれてたんで
りろりとかもうホラーやは後ろのマジで
やばいですなんか昔てきたじゃないですね今後んきいちゃんでしたっけ
なんか黒いパパンの t シャツを着たんですけどもあでも51週間続けてみましたが
効果は全くありませんでしたが重たかったよ俺はで結局人間ってな
ずっと受けて太るんだよちょっと僕しばらく体重を測ってないんで今がちょっと僕の
体重を量ってみます
うわーっこれで俺の
今の体重のすべてがわかってしまういきます
ああああああ
我部キタネーナパ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああああああ
[音楽]
てるやないかい待って前回太った時なんけどたぶんさんのレベルで太ってるんですけど
というわけで外れちゃうぞー
今日からダイエットを開始します色々聞いたんですよ筋トレしてさんや番宣とかで聞い
たんですけども痩せたいときはこれに食事制限がとても大事らしいですね僕今日ティに
食べ物マジで買えます肋骨されたとかサラダチキンと叱った
食べないような生活をまずは1週間かなまず1週間ぐらいちょっとやってみましょう
けれどお菓子はキー410月んして脂っぽいの禁止制
とりあえず1週間これを続けてみましょうのかね俺の体の状況でてもう体重が落ちない
かもしれないそれでまず食事制限をドラッグを落とせるペってみようと思いますと呼び
でついさっきまで俺が覚悟を決めていうことはまぐろたたき丼を腹一杯食ってきて
覚悟すでに趣味ておりますできる今の体重がだいたい7世さん切る蛇縛で73キロて俺
も平均でモデルタイズ俺はどこにいったろぐだ
入ってくるみんな覚えとけはこの滝覚えておいこの体型
俺もこうが大挙
俺はこんな対応してますよまあもう全然が入ってないからね
ちょっとまずは1週間いろいろちょっと試してせてみようと思いますや java 結局
得ない結局痩せてる
かっこいいで細マッチョっていうかこうやっぱでフラット捨てるとかかっこいいのか
なってこの
感じになって思いました頑張って痩せてみようと思いますサーバー